It’s been a busy first week since Elon Musk
took control of Twitter on October 27th.
He appointed himself CEO.
Make that “Chief Twit”
Or Twitter complaint hotline operator.
There were plenty of complaints when Musk
said people would have to start paying $8
a month to keep their blue check mark or to
get one.
AOC wasn’t too happy.
Musk’s response to the Congresswoman?
Pay up.
The SpaceX and Tesla CEO didn’t waste any
time getting down to business.
He ousted Twitter’s nine board of directors
to become the sole director, though he says
being sole director is temporary.
He also started to trim the fat and is reportedly
planning on eliminating nearly half of Twitter’s
workforce, or 3,700 jobs, according to Bloomberg.
These two guys pretended to be laid-off employees…and
gave their names as Rahul Ligma and Daniel
Johnson to reporters who fell for their prank.
But Musk did really start day one as chief
of Twitter by firing top Twitter executives.
CEO Parag Agrawal got the boot
So did Chief Financial Officer Ned Segal
And…legal affairs and policy executive Vijaya
Gadde.
Gadde was reportedly instrumental in permanently
banning Donald Trump from the platform for
controversial tweets related to the Capitol
Hill riot in January 2021.
Musk said banning the former U.S. president
was “a morally bad decision”.
Everyone is wondering whether the former President
will be back on Twitter.
Musk mused that if he “had a dollar for
every time someone asked (him) if Trump is
coming back on this platform, Twitter would
be minting money!”
Before any big changes, he says “Twitter
will be forming a content moderation council
with widely diverse viewpoints.
No major content decisions or account reinstatements
will happen before that council convenes.”
He said the process would take “at least
a few more weeks”.
Musk did buy the platform because he’s a
self-described “free speech absolutist”
Who believes Twitter should be “the digital
town square” but thinks it has gone “too
far in squashing dissenting opinions.”
The final straw appears to have been when
Twitter suspended the Babylon Bee, a Christian
satire account that named U.S. Assistant Secretary
for Health Dr. Rachel Levine its “Man of
the Year”.
Many who are viewed as conservative feel they’ve
been unfairly targeted by Twitter.
Clinical psychologist Jordan Peterson had
his account suspended over his post about
transgender actor Elliot Page, formerly Ellen
Page.
But the suspension will not be lifted unless
I delete the “hateful” tweet in question,
and I would rather die than do that.
Musk replied to Peterson’s daughter that
“Anyone suspended for minor & dubious reasons
will be freed from Twitter jail”.
Now that he’s in charge, Elon Musk won’t
only be freeing people from Twitter jail.
Just like his ambitions for his other companies,
SpaceX and Tesla, he has far bigger plans
for the platform.
In his view, Twitter is “an accelerant to
creating X, the everything app.”
There’s speculation that he wants to replicate
the success of WeChat, which has basically
become the everything app in China.
When YouTuber Steven Mark Ryan of Solving
the Money Problem pointed out it’s “INSANE
that Twitter has not currently implemented
a YouTube clone” - Musk responded with a
wink.
Could we see creators monetizing videos on
Twitter?
Musk polled people to ask if they wanted to
bring back Vine, the short video-sharing app
that Twitter shut down in 2016.
He talked about it being a possible competitor
for TikTok.
All these plans rely on good engineering.
Musk reportedly sent in his trusted Tesla
engineers to inspect Twitter’s code to assess
the company's needs.
They’ll have to tackle the problem of fake
and spam accounts.
In fact, Musk tried to get out of buying Twitter,
believing it wasn’t worth the $44 billion
he offered to take it private…due to the
number of spam bots.
Musk believes the way to defeat the bots while
also making money for Twitter is by charging
you if you want this blue check mark.
This is arguably his most controversial move
during week one.
The blue verification badge has become a status
symbol granted to journalists, celebrities,
politicians, some of whom were furious when
they heard they’d have to pay $19.99 a month
to keep their blue tick as reported by The
Verge.
Musk replied to an unhappy Stephen King that
Twitter needs to pay the bills somehow.
And wondered if the horror author might be
willing to dish out $8 instead.
He called the current system for who has and
doesn’t have the blue tick is “BS” and
that charging $8 a month for anyone who wants
it would mean more “power to the people”.
This would be part of the Twitter Blue subscription
service which comes with other benefits.
Although Musk has long boasted that Tesla
does not pay for advertising, advertising
has been crucial to Twitter’s survival.
General Motors temporarily pulled ads from
Twitter following the takeover.
Musk tried to reassure advertisers that Twitter
would be a respected advertising platform.
In an open letter, he stressed that he doesn’t
want Twitter to “become a free-for-all hellscape,
where anything can be said with no consequences!”
He also said he bought Twitter “to help
humanity, whom I love.”
Will people love the new Twitter?
Users have begun to notice some changes.
When the White House boasted seniors are getting
the biggest social security increase in a
decade thanks to President Biden, context
checkers pointed out it’s because inflation
has been the highest in decades.
The White House then deleted the tweet.
Musk can only hope that Twitter soars to new
heights, like his rocket company SpaceX.
Though some have vowed to leave.
However you feel, let that sink in, that a
new boss is in town.
Can’t help it, let that sink in.
Twitter is now a private company and will
no longer be listed on the New York stock
exchange.
However, millions of investors have already
dropped their shares in the last few months,
as it got too volatile.
And their caution is well-founded;
The classic 60/40 portfolio of stocks and
bonds,
The go-to investing method for decades,
has lost around 34% this year.
As a result, Goldman Sachs says portfolios
need to be rebalanced, to avoid further losses.
They highlight the importance of investing
in real assets that have historically outperformed
in volatile conditions.
Assets like fine art.
And it’s why Masterworks is seeing increased
demand this year.
Masterworks lets you invest in multimillion-dollar
paintings, from legends like Picasso.
You can buy shares in these paintings without
owning millions yourself.
These are not NFTs.
Contemporary art has outpaced the S&P 500
by 131%, for the last 26 years.
Even during the bull market of the last decade.
In October, Masterworks sold this painting
by George Condo for a 21.5% net return.
In fact, six of Masterworks’ seven sales
have brought in over 20% net returns.
Masterworks has a waitlist to join their 550,000-plus
members.
But you can skip the waitlist by clicking
the custom link in the description.
That’s masterworks.art/newsthink, masterworks.art/newsthink
to get started investing in fine art.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.